today's topic kwame brown now uh this
wasn't a topic that i had any plans on
covering
however stephen a smith decided to go on
a little rant recently
and i thought it was salacious so i
figured it'd be worth covering
if you aren't aware who kwame brown is
kwame brown is a
first-round draft pick in the nba played
about 13 seasons
uh and was basically known around the
national basketball association the nba
as kwame
or mr inept uh they kept calling him a
bust
somebody who couldn't play and
recently even though he's retired many
years ago uh kwami's brown's name
resurfaced
across a few podcasts at which point
kwame who's been very silent for the
last 20 years or so
decided to get on social media and speak
about it and there was a huge up war
he got a whole bunch of other large
creators involved but essentially he was
just like yo yo stop
playing with my name is the gist of it
and stephen a smith who was the person
who was in the lead of making fun of
kwame brown and constantly talking about
him
uh recently decided to retort other most
normal circumstances i have considerably
better things to do with my time
but kwame brown wanted my attention
but you got it now i didn't want to have
to do this
but he made me look look at the way he's
framing it
he's framing it as if kwame is some kind
of fly who's
bothering him there's a certain
arrogance to stephen a smith in this
kind of scenario where he doesn't even
consider the fact that he could be wrong
so already the framing of this
conversation is really going south
i don't have a single negative thing to
say
about kwame brown the person
nothing personal never have
and no one out here has been attacking
him personally
either that includes gilbert arenas who
did not attack him personally
it includes stephen jackson who did not
attack him personally it doesn't include
charlemagne the god either see and this
is my problem
stephen a smith you're a journalist do a
bit of research
you would know that charlemagne went out
of his way to
docs kwame charlemagne got on the
breakfast club and apologized because he
realized that his
attack got personal i want to apologize
the kwame brown and kwame brown's family
self uh i revealed too much information
about that man's family and even all
that stuff is public record
some things just don't need to be said
on the radio and they definitely don't
need to be said by me because the
conversation didn't even have to go
there the conversation should have been
about
basketball yes leave kwame brown alone
because he achieved a goal
and a dream that 1.3 of ncaa seniors
will achieve and 0.03 of high school
seniors you know how
small a number that is he was talking
about his brother his
father what they had done how they're
zero
that is extremely personal so when you
media personalities get out there and
act like you guys never crossed the line
that's crazy to me and you're a
journalist and you didn't even do this
minimum amount of research but you got
enough time to get up on espn
and have this highlight reel of kwame
and get all your producers to help you
put this together and write this up but
you didn't research that
steven jackson said threats to kwame say
if i can't shoot these streets we can
i can get my partners to come after you
and it didn't get personal
and you call yourself a journalist stay
off the weed and this is why people
don't take media personalities seriously
you're bugging but kwame brown's been
getting personal
with everybody these days talking a
whole bunch of smack
saying we don't support black men really
really please why is stephen a smith
acting surprised by this
stephen a smith has been criticized for
being anti-black men for a long time
there's been a plenty of segments about
it
he's always talked about the fact that
people have been saying this about him
so when he gets up here and acts
incredulous it's like breath
i can pull up a whole bunch of clips of
you on espn and talk about how dare you
guys say i'm against black men
stay off the weed the only negative
thing
anybody ever said about kwame brown
is that he couldn't play a liquor
basketball
news flash that wasn't a lie
when you put yourself and you put your
game out there
in the best league in the world people
can comment on it
because you're putting your talents on
public display
how you gonna say someone's a a scrub
and can't play
and yet they made 70 million dollars in
the nba and were there for 13 seasons
think about that how did he constantly
get
rehired and brought to different places
played 60 to 80 games per season
and then you want to sit there and say
he can't play
are we to believe that stephen a smith
happens to know better than every single
gm and
exec in the league come on bro
i'm not saying he's shaq i'm not even
saying he's one of the top 10 top 100
top one
none of that i'm saying when you say he
can't play
does that say anything about kwame or
does that say something about the league
the basketball player we ain't talking
about you the man
we ain't talking about you the father
but you are you are talking about him
the man when you're saying you didn't
put in the work
when you're saying you didn't put in the
effort you're you're questioning his
character
your questioning is dedication it's not
just about the game at that point
you're questioning someone's work ethic
becomes a lot more than just that
so i think you're not being very honest
with what your criticism is and what
links you went to
when you're saying this stuff you're
being disingenuous stephen a smith it's
okay it's okay to get on the air and
realize you use the wrong words it's
okay to realize you crossed the line you
already know this because you've
apologized in the past
stephen a smith used the word provoke
when it comes to women sometimes
inciting certain situations with men
and the next day he got on and made this
lengthy ass apology talking about
i'm so sorry i used the wrong words i
should have thought of the impact i
could have on individuals
who are going through certain situations
so you have the ability to do that
when it's time to be politically correct
but when a brother says hey man maybe
you lay off and don't need to call me a
scrub
good morning on friday speaking right
here on first take on the subject
i made what can only amount to the most
egregious era of my career
while elaborating on thoughts concerning
the nfl's ruling versus ray rice
following a domestic dispute with his
then fiance i ventured beyond the scope
of our discussion by alluding to a
woman's role
in such heinous matters going so far as
to use the word provoke
in my diatribe this was not my intent it
is not what i was trying to say
yet the failure to clearly articulate
something different
lies squarely on my shoulders to say
what i actually said was foolish is an
understatement to say i was wrong
is obvious to apologize to say i'm sorry
doesn't do to matter it's proper justice
to be quite honest
but i do sincerely apologize how are you
not going to expect him to feel some
type of way
like i said you use your platform every
day call people scrubs call people not
hard working
question their character say people are
idiots all this other stuff
but now when people start to get a
little bit personal with you you're not
a fan of it and i'm not saying i endorse
everything kwame said i definitely think
he crossed a few lines i agree
but your media personalities do it all
the time and i just i just think it's
crazy how quick
stephen a smith was there shucking and
driving when he used the word provoke
but now when people were like hey man it
was kind of excessive the way you called
him a scrub for years and went out of
your way
whether it was at university speeches
high school speeches
conferences you went out of your way to
mention kwame's name and to question his
work ethic and his character
260 270 10 years in the league
and there is no noticeable improvement
whatsoever
that's my issue that you would joe scrub
no
offense having that just said that
i mean that's just blasphemy you should
apologize for bringing that up
and when i look at somebody you have an
opportunity to make millions of dollars
playing a game
for a couple of hours a day you can't
maximize that to the greatest of your
ability and make it happen
you can't do that that's inexcusable bro
it just is again if you're a scrum
you're a scrub
but in five years from now you're still
doing it
we got a problem that's a major problem
you have
nothing else to do how come you're not
better
how are you in the league for 10 years
and you're still the same scrub you won
in 2001
i have a problem with that before kwame
brown got treated
i went to the lakers game
and it was a moment where they were up
comfortably
so phil jackson decides
to call kwame brown's number
[Music]
on five consecutive offensive players he
did that for kwame brown
first play he bounced it off his foot
second play turn around jump shot
air ball
he got stripped and then he got moved
four
you didn't see anything wrong with all
of that nothing
but use the word provoke and you got on
an apology tour
so when people call you a sellout
stephen a smith understand where it
comes from
i i'm disappointed in a lot of what i'm
seeing right now i feel like as black
folks we often legislate
and we handle all of our business online
and social platforms this is unfortunate
sometimes it's necessary but i'm just
not a fan of it it just seems like drama
you know i mean
it just looks like the family that's
always out on the media
airing out their business it's messy
it's unnecessary
but at the same time it's like yeah
folks like this been doing it on these
platforms forever and never get checked
those are my thoughts maybe you guys
disagree tell us what you guys think in
the comments below
[Music]
oh